le oneplus 11 vient d'arriver alors tout
nouveau smartphone si les oneplus en
partenariat avec un seul Blade alors un
seul Blaze à la troisième année que le
partenariat est là avec oneplus alors je
vous le dis tout de suite l'année
dernière j'étais resté un peu sur ma fin
sur le oneplus 10 pro je trouvais qu'il
était bien il fonctionnait bien mais
qu'en photo qui manquait un truc donc on
va regarder aujourd'hui si oneplus a
rehausser sa copie avec son one plus 11
je vous le dis directement il n'y aura
pas de oneplus 11 protocole il n'a pas
été annoncé donc aujourd'hui on a
uniquement une version et ce qui est
déjà bien c'est le oneplus 11 vous allez
voir parce que il y a plein de petites
subtilités notamment par rapport à ce
que je vous ai dit chez Samsung autre
fois vous allez voir vous allez
comprendre pourquoi on va regarder ça
est-ce que vous êtes prêt est-ce que
vous êtes prêts allez on y va
waouh alors regardez en fait la boîte
est ici c'est toujours la même boîte à
oneplus ils aiment bien avoir ces jolies
petites boîtes rouges ils aiment bien
vous mettre à l'intérieur leur petit hop
là voilà on ouvre ça comme ça alors
petit câble rouge que vous avez là et
puis là ils nous ont mis un gros bloc de
charge très gros bloc de charge de 100
watts alors je sais pas si vous le savez
mais en fait oneplus aujourd'hui c'est
énormément rapproché de oppo c'est la
même boîte c'est le même groupe donc on
a ici de la super bouc voilà super book
c'était un terme déposé par repos une
marque de oppo mais qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui sur oneplus parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va une place et au pot
c'est comme ça c'est pas tout à fait la
même histoire mais ça se rapproche il y
a vraiment des liens de parenté qui sont
extrêmement forts donc voilà il garde
néanmoins toujours leur identité et leur
slogan never Seattle ok ça marche et le
smartphone il est là alors regardez ce
smartphone il est intéressant pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a plein de choses à venir
raconter déjà il est joli moi je l'aime
bien j'aime bien cette idée alors en
plus il y a deux versions moi ce que
j'ai comme version s'appelle le Titan
black est un algreen qui existe aussi
d'ailleurs je vous mets les liens en bas
dans la description juste un petit coup
d'oeil j'aime bien ce petit temps black
pourquoi parce que il a un côté un peu
doux voyez au niveau du revêtement il y
a un côté un peu soyeux et je trouve ça
très très chouette alors on garde un peu
le même design avec l'appareil photo
même si c'est pas exactement la même
chose que sur le oneplus 10 pro l'année
dernière légèrement mis sur le côté avec
tout le contour en acier inoxydable et
là on a alors une manière plus content
on l'avait plus peut-être sur le le XT
on avait plus le petit slider là et ça
me rendait très malheureux c'est fait
vraiment partie de l'histoire en fait de
oneplus alors pour ceux qui le savent
pas en fait le slider il permet de venir
changer entre le mode sonnerie le mode
vibreur et le mode silencieux tout en
maçonnerie ici c'est vibreur et là c'est
silencieux comme ça vous l'avez
directement sous le doigt et ça c'est un
truc sympa parce que j'aime bien il y a
vraiment un côté ADN de oneplus qu'on
retrouve ici avec ce bouton et en plus
qui est très bien c'est que si vous
regardez bien vous voyez il y a le côté
en acier inoxydable ici là et en fait ça
se retrouve ici sur le côté alors bon
effectivement il y a une petite
séparation ici au niveau de la
fabrication mais sinon c'est
sensiblement la même chose vous êtes sur
votre bouton pour venir l'allumer dans
le récit de l'autre côté les boutons de
volume toujours un capteur d'empreinte
digitale qui est situé sous l'écran et
qui marche bien et qui déverrouille très
rapidement on va retrouver le module
photo avec trois caméras à l'arrière on
va se détailler dans quelques instants
et puis c'est un smartphone que je
trouve très cool légèrement aplat sur le
dessus en fait dessus et dessous ce qui
fait que si vous y prenez bien vous
arriverez à le faire tenir tout seul
voilà il y a tout seul tu es pratique
alors il est en bois lourd il fait 205 g
c'est pas le smartphone le plus léger
que j'ai connu mais bon ok
petite particularité vous avez au dos
encore ningoria glace 5 à l'avance un
Corning Horia glace victime si on n'a
pas la dernière génération le Corning
gorille à glace victus deuxième version
c'est la première version mais qui va
déjà très bien soyez tranquille
là-dessus ils ont toujours très jolis
écrans ici c'est un fluide un molette
c'est un très grand écran de 6,7 pouces
avec une résolution en qHD plus alors
cette jolie résolution en qHD plus elle
est très bien mais elle va être un peu
plus énergivore si vous venez vous
regardez vous venez ici dans affichage
et dans luminosité vous avez également
un mode sombre ça c'est du point de vue
logiciel c'est à vous de voir ce que
vous préférez mais les deux iront très
très bien le confort des yeux à voir si
vous voulez le mettre ou pas moi je suis
en Full HD plus là si vous regardez tout
de suite au niveau de ma résolution
parce que si je passe en qHD plus et
bien c'est très joli j'en aurai un peu
plus mais ça va venir consommer
davantage et il me le dit directement
donc on va rester ici en foulage des
plus autre truc qui est intéressant
c'est au niveau du taux de
rafraîchissement et bien il vous fait
choisir entre élever élever c'est
jusqu'à 120 Hertz ou alors 60 hertz
parce que et c'est là que c'est
intéressant vous avez la technologie
ltpo 3.0 alors cette fameuse technologie
ltpo et vous permet quoi et bien elle
vous permet de descendre jusqu'à 1 Hz
une image par seconde vous passez de 1 à
Hertz jusqu'à maximum 120 Hertz si par
exemple vous êtes sur le always on
display vous voyez là je suis sur le
always on display donc il y a pas grand
chose qui apparaît et bien j'ai pas
besoin d'avoir 60 images par seconde ça
va venir consommer beaucoup de choses
pour pas grand-chose et si grâce à
technologie ltpo on arrive à redescendre
à une image par seconde ce qui fait que
je consomme pas grand-chose mais lorsque
vous lisez par exemple ebook tout
simplement et bien vous avez pas besoin
non plus de monter à 120 images par
seconde même pas du 60 donc vous serez à
10 images par seconde si par exemple
vous venez jouer à des jeux ici ben
voyez je vais monter
par seconde donc ça c'est quand même
vachement cool alors ça va dépendre une
fois de plus des jeux tous les jeux
n'ont pas besoin de monter à temps
d'image par seconde mais si vous voulez
faire vous pouvez le faire d'ailleurs
puisque j'en parle puisque je vous parle
des jeux ici et bien on a très
clairement pour moi un smartphone qui
est conçu pour le gaming vous avez ici
ce qui s'est mis aujourd'hui en terme de
processeur vous avez le stand dragon 8
Jen 2 qui est vaccès sur l'intelligence
artificielle je vous en ai déjà parlé de
ce processeur qui marche super bien j'ai
beaucoup de voitures de police autour de
moi c'est l'angoisse absolue bonjour à
tous les policiers qui nous regardent la
petite particularité que vous allez
avoir au niveau de la question de la
performance c'est qu'en fait vous avez
deux configurations et si vous allez
avoir une première configuration en 8
plus 128 et une deuxième configuration
que j'ai moi ici qui va être du 16 + 256
en fait ils nous ont fait à peu près la
même chose que Samsung à savoir que
lorsque vous êtes sur la version avec
128 Go de stockage vous êtes sur l'UFS
3.1 c'est une bonne techno qu'on avait
l'année dernière sauf que sur la version
en 256 Go de stockage vous êtes sur
l'UFS 4.0 qui va aller 2 fois plus vite
ça sera donc beaucoup plus rapide en
lecture et en écriture par rapport à la
version 128 Go il y a une vraie grosse
différence quand même hein parce que si
vous voulez pour de la vidéo si vous
voulez pour du gaming et bien vous allez
pas exploiter le smartphone de la même
manière bien que vous ayez une super
puce très rapide derrière donc bon une
fois de plus il va falloir voir par
rapport à son budget parce que je vous
le dis directement j'ai les tarifs ici
ce smartphone en 8 + 128 coûte 849 € et
en 16 + 256 919 € alors fatalement il
faut venir rajouter 70 balles pour
monter sur la version la plus puissante
mais je dirais que quand on a un smart
sur un smartphone entre 850 et 900
quelques balles est-ce que ça vaut pas
le coup de venir ajouter 70 € si vous en
avez la possibilité parce que c'est là
où vous aurez le plus de performances au
niveau de ce smartphone donc ça c'est
vraiment important puis je vous l'avais
dit c'est Samsung qui nous l'a fait avec
le S23 sur le premier le S23 en 120 sur
le svel3 en 256 soit la version 128 vous
avez de l'uefs 3.0 et sur la version 256
vous avez de la version en
ufs 4.0 alors après je me pose la
question est-ce que les constructeurs ne
sont pas capables aujourd'hui de mettre
de l'UFS 4.0 sur l'assemblée peut-être
est-ce que c'est pas rentable j'en sais
rien en tout cas vous en avez pas ici
alors après par contre la techno drame
c'est exactement la même que vous allez
avoir d'un côté et de l'autre c'est à
dire que vous êtes sur la 5x qui ira
bien de tous les côtés absolument aucun
problème et puisque je vous parlais
également de la performance mais écoutez
j'ai fait un petit benchmark sur un
toutou je vous montre le résultat
franchement c'est pas mal du tout c'est
très efficace comme smartphone on est un
million 145000 875 pour vous le dire sur
le S23 plus c'était un million
203342 je suis un tout petit peu
au-dessus mais ça se tient dans un
mouchoir de poche donc on est quasiment
la même chose pour savoir c'est la même
puce et les mêmes techno de RAM et le
stockage donc ici ça se tient réellement
alors je voulais rapidement finir sur
cet écran parce que je vous en parlais
certifié je garde plus Dolby vision à
cœur ratio 20,1/9 ici très allongé donc
vraiment format cinéma pour le coup moi
il y a un truc qui m'a vraiment surpris
et intéressé sur ce smartphone c'est que
je trouve que l'audio est super bon
c'est très fort très très fort attention
pas mettre trop trop fort mais vous
allez voir c'est extrêmement fort on a
du grave
la sa facture un peu alors lorsque je
baisse vous voyez drastiquement je perds
tout de suite quand même mais je trouve
que le son est quand même fort mais
c'est pas mal parce que quand vous le
mettez de la voix c'est efficace
[Applaudissements]
bien alors je vous dis ça sature au bout
d'un moment alors une vraie différence
en fait le haut-parleur qui est situé là
et l'autre qui est situé ici là mais je
trouve ça pas mal c'est pas totalement
bien équilibré comme si vous aviez la
même direction le même directivité au
niveau des haut-parleurs mais le
résultat global je trouve ça bien le son
est vraiment une bonne qualité donc ça
ça me reste vachement surpris donc pour
une expérience multimédia vous êtes
vraiment bien alors le mieux c'est de
venir mettre des bandes et puisqu'on
parle de buzz sachez que je déteste pas
mais je vous le montre quand même
oneplus sortable sans les bugs Pro 2 que
vous pouvez également venir acheter et
qui coûte cela j'ai le tarif ils sont à
179 € si vous voulez la complète le full
package et bien vous pouvez c'est
complètement possible mais l'expérience
audio comme elle est là elle est très
très bien alors une fois de plus vous
avez pas de prise jack hein ça se fait
de moins en moins donc vous allez pas
venir en retrouver ni au dessus ni en
dessous d'aucun côté donc vous allez
venir ici utiliser des buds ça ira très
très bien on a du Dolby Atmos enfin bref
le son est très très bon et sachez que
ici le Bluetooth pour ceux qui veulent
savoir c'est du 5.3 et vous avez une
chute deck on va le dire comme ça vous
avez une pléthore de codex et on va être
le plus poli à PTX ça PTX HD lhdc à csbc
côté batterie on a une grosse batterie
de 5000 mAh c'est la même chose qu'on va
retrouver chez Samsung sur le S23 ultra
donc bon très grosse batterie ça fait
l'affaire je redis de la charge très
rapide ici on s'en watts c'est un peu la
force ici qu'on va retrouver que cette
super boucle après oneplus vous dit on a
mis tout en place pour venir protéger
votre batterie éviter qu'elle surchauffe
vous allez en 100 watts directement
après ça va descendre la charge un peu
plus basse 65 compagnie si et ça
première préserver la durée de vie de
votre batterie mais vous le rechargez
très rapidement on appelle 20 minutes
donc on vient pas ici se poser la
question de l'autonomie est-ce que j'ai
une bonne autonomie ou pas oui de toute
façon ça va ça fonctionne mais en plus
de ça grâce à votre banque de charge 100
watt vous êtes tranquille parce que si
on vient un peu aligner les planètes si
vous voulez surtout sur la version 256
Go vous avez un processeur qui est pas
du tout énergivore qui va bien le saint
dragon 8 GN2 vous avez un écran en LTP
au 3.0 qui en plus en fluide à Molay
vous savez que quand on est sur de la
molette et bien tous les pixels noirs
sont des pixels à l'état donc on vient
pas trop consommer comment on va
descendre en terme de Hertz sur le
always on display il y a 1 Hertz lorsque
vous avez pas besoin vous allez venir
moins consommer donc le fait qu'il y a
une variation un peu totalement
optimisée de la part de vos smartphones
ça c'est très très cool le fait si vous
allez sur la version 256 Go et bien
l'uefs 4.0 est aussi moins énergivore
que l'UFS 3.1 que vous aurez sur la
version 128 Go le fait d'avoir une
grosse batterie aussi ça permet d'aller
un peu plus loin donc ça c'est vachement
cool et puis après c'est toutefois vous
venez à manquer un peu de batterie avec
tout ça et bien vous avez de la
recherche sur Watt donc c'est un vrai
smartphone passe partout pour ça donc ça
c'est très très chouette autre truc que
j'aime beaucoup ici c'est l'expérience
logiciel vous êtes sur oxygène ouest 13
basé sur l'Android 13 en fait ça sera
proche de Color os de oppo puisque je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure et ce sont
les mêmes boîtes en fait même s'il y a
quand même deux entités réellement
différentes c'est très lisible très bien
peut venir tout personnaliser votre fond
d'écran vos icônes vos différentes
couleurs ça c'est vachement cool donc on
peut faire plein de choses c'est très
très bien classé très très bien groupé
on s'est réellement où sont les choses
personnellement j'aime bien j'ai une
expérience que j'ai toujours bien aimé
que je continue à bien aimer puis j'aime
bien ce que fait au pot également au
niveau de son espace logiciel donc vous
voyez il y a un truc qui marche vraiment
bien ici là il y a un autre point qu'il
faut qu'on vienne regarder c'est ce qui
m'avait un peu déçu l'année dernière sur
le oneplus 10 pro c'est la partie photo
alors ils nous ont mis un triptyque ici
vous avez trois capteurs photos vous
allez avoir un grand angle de 50
mégapixel vous allez avoir un ultra
grand angle de 48 mégapixels et un
téléobjectif x 2 optique de 32
mégapixels sans oublier votre caméra de
selfie qui se plante juste ici de 16
mégapixels alors bon tout ça c'est bien
joli c'est signé à ce Blade et je
trouvais que sur leur premier smartphone
en partenariat qu'un seul Blade c'était
le oneplus 9 et bien on avait de bons
résultats avec le oneplus 10 pro j'avais
été déçu je trouvais que c'était moins
bon que ce que nous proposait au pot sur
son fight X5 pro veut dire qu'ils
avaient tellement bien bossé au pot
là-dessus c'était cool donc là on va
venir regarder si le résultat est à la
hauteur ici dans l'ensemble je trouve
que c'est pas mal les photos elle manque
un peu de contraste on va regarder tout
au long c'est à dire que il s'en sort
très très bien au niveau algorithmique
le calcul est très très bon et une fois
de plus comme vous avez le somagone 8
GN2 basé sur glia il est très très bon
et il va vous faire de très belles
choses le ciel j'adore très bien on voit
bien les plantes ici tout va bien
j'aurais aimé que ce soit un poil plus
pêche au niveau de l'image vous voyez un
peu plus contrastée mais dans l'ensemble
le résultat est bon alors le travail va
entendre est un peu moins bon il y a une
différence de colorimétrie ici et puis
on a le zoom optique x 2 après on peut
vous rapprocher en x 5 x 10 x 20 on va
oublier le X 20 c'est pas terrible ici
voyez je trouve ça pas mal mais il
manque un peu de contraste au niveau des
photos ça qui va faire un peu la
différence avec notamment un Samsung
Galaxy S23 parce que si vous prenez le
oneplus 11 en version 256 Go on est
quasiment au même prix on se rapproche
en tout cas on a un tout petit peu en
dessous et on se rapproche du tarif du
Samsung Galaxy S23 qui même s'il est en
ufs 3.1 sur la version 128 Go de
stockage à ce tarif là et si on veut
monter sur la version 256 Go on lui a
fait ce 4.0 il faut passer au-dessus des
1000 balles mais la photo sera un peu
meilleure regardez si donc là je
t'envoie c'est pas mal ultra grand temps
que j'aime pas trop il y a une vraie
différence de colorimétrie c'est ça
c'est un peu dans l'ensemble c'est pas
mal ils sortent de des choses qui sont
pas dégueu mais je trouve qu'il manque
un petit peu voyez des fois un côté un
peu peps regardez je vous montre des
photos je viens un peu trop zoomer en
fait ce qu'il faut venir retenir ici
c'est que le grand angle fonctionne bien
ultra grand-angle est un peu moins bon
faut beaucoup de lumière faut éteindre
nourrir le X 2 me va bien et au-delà de
ça tout de suite on a vraiment perdre en
qualité donc on évite alors là macro
j'en ai fait un peu aussi pour vous
montrer je la trouve pas folle un très
honnêtement je trouve que le résultat au
niveau de la macro et pas terrible
autant sur l'écran du smartphone c'est
assez joli mais lorsque vous regardez en
vrai là c'est pas trop mal on arrive à
avoir un peu de détails ici mais je
trouve qu'il y a plein de moments on
arrive vraiment pas à trouver la bonne
distance à avoir le bon rendu il faut
vraiment sur ordinateur pour son compte
c'est la qualité est bonne donc bon on
loupe pas mal de photos là je suis voulu
venir voir au niveau de la gestion de
notre lumière donc là on voit bien ici
là je trouve que voilà ça va être un peu
plus pêchu il a eu un peu plus de
malicieux au niveau de l'expo une fois
de plus un peu de macro et j'ai beaucoup
de mal à faire le point là c'était pas
mal mais il lui manque une vraie
personnalité ou on va se dire tiens
c'est un super photophone et il lui
manque quelques trucs je trouve que si
vous voulez un très bon photophone avec
un bon rapport qualité prix vous allez
sur le pixel 6a qui fera bien meilleur
photo qui coûter moins cher si pour vous
la photo c'est pas le truc trop hyper
important et vous voulez vraiment de la
performance brute un très bon smartphone
avec belle performance recherche très
rapide vous pouvez aller sur le oneplus
11 la photo est pas mal mais bon là
typiquement je vais lui faire le mode
portrait mode portrait avec un seul
Blade alors moi le portrait il est pas
mauvais hein ça reconnait bien ma statue
plus vous avez différents effets
différents filtres vous voyez là je vais
nous pousser un peu plus là j'ai fermé
en fait je vais être de 8 et là je dois
être à 7 et quelques vous voyez une
vraie différence c'est pas mauvais ça
fonctionne bien après vous avez
différents fait filtre de colorimétrie
que nous propose un seul Blade ici bon
why not c'est pas mal on peut même venir
chercher quelques petites poules alors
là je trouve c'est pas mal parce qu'on a
quand même bien de détails vous voyez
sur la tête des poules et je trouvais ça
bien fait plutôt pas mal regardez là je
fais du zoomer un peu sur la tête de la
poule en X 2 et je trouve que
effectivement le X 2 optique là il
marche quand même vachement bien la
source celle-là là c'est quand même pas
mal du tout regardez je trouve que c'est
vraiment pas mal hein pareil on est en X
2 du détail on l'a bien ici je trouve
que ça marche bien alors les moutons on
peut venir chercher un petit mouton on
peut se rapprocher on va voir le mouton
et en venant transhumer la qualité pas
et pas terrible c'est un peu dommage
alors la caméra de selfie elle est pas
mal elle est pas mal si vous restez sur
un mode un peu classique je suis venu un
peu la chercher vous voyez
et malgré tout il y a un truc qui est
quand même assez joli c'est pas parfait
c'est assez joli alors il vient quand
même chercher vachement à compenser et
là je le voyais pas ce ciel bleu et les
nuages donc il a un peu les tous les
smartphones qui font ça aujourd'hui qui
ont vraiment tendance à venir conduire
une sensation un peu de jours des fois
la nuit et on perd un peu ça ce côté
nuit mais dans l'ensemble c'est pas
mauvais vous voyez ce que je vais
approché vraiment c'est ça c'est que des
fois au niveau des éclairages de ville
il a un petit peu de mal ici bon il est
pas le seul c'est un peu le truc que
j'ai d'ailleurs reprocher sinon dans
l'ensemble c'est pas mauvais en plus de
ça vous avez bien évidemment du wifi 6
alors pas de wifi 6 celui-ci Wi-Fi 6
vous avez du NFC pour le paiement des
matérialisé avec Google paye et puis il
y a une petite particularité que je
voulais voir avec vous c'est à dire que
vous pouvez venir filmer effectivement
en vidéo jusqu'en 8k mais uniquement de
la 8k à 24 images par seconde vous avez
pas de 30 images par seconde pour voir
qu'on a le même processeur que ce que
nous propose Samsung sur son Galaxy S23
qu'on est bien en ufs 4.0 et bien non
vous filmez uniquement 24 images par
seconde en 8k alors après très
honnêtement de vous à moi est-ce que
vous allez venir filmer en 8k 24 images
par seconde la réponse est très
probablement non mais on se dit qu'à
tarif quasi équivalent on aurait bien
aimé avoir la même chose donc voilà je
sais pas pourquoi on peut pas venir
monter autant de toute façon on peut
venir filmer en 4K jusqu'à 60 images par
seconde ici pas de souci et puis si on
veut regarder rapidement l'expérience
logiciel au niveau de la photo et de la
vidéo pour moi ça fonctionne très très
bien c'est clair c'est lisible c'est
joli vous avez en plus différents modes
notamment le mode à celle Blade
professionnel si vous êtes photographe
que vous aimez la photo graphique vous
voulez venir vous amuser bien vous
pouvez le faire venir shooter en JPEG en
haut en haut plus ici il y a vraiment de
quoi faire donc absolument aucun
problème également ici ça smartphone qui
est assez complet je vais lui reprocher
je vous dis effectivement qu'il y a deux
trois petits trucs qui en photo sont
rares il lui manque un peu de tout petit
personnalité mais sinon il est pas mal
je préfère vraiment cette copie par
rapport au one plus 10 pro sortie
l'année dernière il est très puissant il
est très polyvalent l'audio est très bon
l'écran est de bonne qualité la
recharger rapide il est efficient et
autonome il marche bien donc c'est un
joli smartphone et je vous le dis une
fois de plus le tarif c'est 849 € sur la
version 828 et sur la version 16 256 919
euros vous pouvez également avoir les
bugs à 179 je vous mets une fois de plus
le lien en bas dans la description pour
moi ce smartphone est bien est-ce que
maintenant il est idéalement placé en
terme de tarif par rapport à ce qu'il
fait bien il a affaire beaucoup de
concurrence c'est pas évident si on veut
de la très jolie photo bah j'ai que ça
me saoule on sera au dessus on sera
également au-dessus avec le pixel 7 pro
et les pixel 7 et le pixel 6a qui seront
bien meilleur en photo il est bon moi je
trouve que c'est vraiment un smartphone
que je viendrai recommander à quelqu'un
qui veut un très haut de gamme quelqu'un
qui veut un smartphone qui est un
superbe écran bonne audio qui veut
beaucoup de performance qui veut de la
recharge très rapide il vient cocher les
cases là où Samsung ira uniquement 45
watts avec son S23 plus et son S23 ultra
tandis que sur le S23 il sera qu'en 25
watts bloc de charge non inclus donc ici
vous avez le bloc de charge inclus donc
vous voyez ça c'est vraiment ce qui fait
la force de ce smartphone c'est pas
forcément la photo mais si la photo vous
en foutez et que vous voulez quelque
chose de très performant efficient et
rapide et qui est très très bon et
endurant et bien je dirais que le
oneplus 11 est une très très bonne copie
à vous de me dire maintenant ce que vous
en pensez ce qu'il vous plaît vous botte
vous intéresse est-ce qu'il peut vous IP
marquez moi ça bien évidemment en bas
dans les commentaires nous on se
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler de smartphone de quelque chose et
ça c'est très chouette je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]